Justin Bieber mocking Taylor Swift last
week when Taylor appeared on The Tonight
Show Jimmy Fallon surprised her with a
video of her after getting LASIK eye
surgery and freaking out over a banana
was so cute and in case you missed it
here's the video
[Music]
she found a snack
stop you can't cry that does not it's
bound to be what you're doing I try to
get them to give you do for you from
okay but what do we do it this no it's
my head honey okay don't you don't want
to cry that's not what you want to do go
your way sleep eating plan okay I'm not
asleep my mind is alive okay people did
they thought it was funny was endearing
except for maybe Justin Bieber so in an
Instagram live from Haley Bieber his
wife Justin can be seen in the
background grabbing a banana to eat and
it seems like he's mocking this
post-surgery video take a look that was
so funny hey Justin today the heav'n
history of not getting along most
recently Justin came to scooter Braun's
defense afternoo acquires Taylor's music
catalog earlier in the year with Taylor
calling out scooter for his history of
bullying her yeah
so you know it does seem like he's
playing up the video we know that he's
not been a fan of hers as of late but
something that's been really intense in
their lives I feel like the Bieber's
have been everywhere these days
you've got the Justin Haley second time
they got married last week then they
start together in the music video for
Justin's new song ten thousand hours and
now they've teamed up for a pretty
steamy Calvin Klein campaign take a look
you're unbelievable
you're unbelievable
[Music]
that's a wicked commercial I love it
Romo so what do you think of the whole
thing about him mocking Taylor Swift
okay so especially with their history I
personally think he's just teasing I
don't think he he's doing it to be
totally nasty but it seemed mocking yeah
totally but in my opinion yeah yeah and
I wonder if he's doing it for a reason
as well I mean there's like his chest
music is right commercial he's you know
it's just it's time right now what's
this part of it you know we always say
that sometimes you're putting yourself
out there so you can be out there people
are talking about you exactly Nelson
agrees of you saying everybody can make
fun of it if you have it out there Chloe
saying I don't think he's throwing shade
faded thing jb needs to stop so the drum
is actually escalated a little bit so
taylor swift as we know have really
dedicated fans and a fan completely went
after haley and said you know made fun
of her modeling career said how dare you
you know take this instagram live video
you're going after Taylor Swift doesn't
go after Justin Bieber even though
Justin was the one who seemed to be
making her and then Haley's responded
and said wow I've never seen I've never
been so forcefully angry at somebody
that I've never met before maybe you
guys need to calm down
Wow smart he knows what he's doing he
knows he is